Mình bốn tháng từ, tại đại lệ bưởng nhân dân bất kênh,
tổ mi thứ chủ tính nước to lâm đã hội kiến chủ tệ chính giề tòan Quốc Trung Quốc vườn hổn lên,
trong khun khổ chuyên thăm cấp nhắn nước đến Trung Quốc,
trong khổ khí trên thành và kỳ mở.
Hà bên bày tỏ huy mừng trước những tiến chiển quan trọng của quan hệ hại đàn,
hãy nước, đông thời tiến sẽ tình hình của mỗi bên sau đại hội mấy bốn của đảng công sản Việt Nam,
và việc Trung Quốc thông qua khuy ai phát triển năm năm lần thứ May.
Tổ mi thứ chủ tính nước to lâm khẳng đề,
Việt Nam có trọng đặc biệt quan hệ đối tác hợp tác chính lực quan dịch,
và mông muốn làm sâu sắc hơn tình cầy chính chi,
đông chỉ đề nghỉ thu gẩn bị mạc nhất nối,
lý tưởng miệm tin, lợi íc phát triển và văn hoá lòng dân.
Hà bên cần rý chỉ tiếp xúc cấp cao,
nâng cao hiệu quả hợp tác trên tất cả các cầy đàn,
nhắn nước và cùng cố chủ cột của phòng anh nền,
bên cạnh lĩnh vực xin thống,
tổ mi thứ chủ tính nước nhắn mạnh việc tạo biểm sản trong hạn tình dấu thông đường sắc,
chuyển đối số và các công nghệ chính lực như AI bán dẫn,
đông chỉ cũng đề nghỉ phát tri vai cho của mặt trận tổ cu vệ Nam và chính nghiệp Trung Quốc,
trong việc tăng cường ra luyên nhân dân,
tuyên trên hiệu nghiệp và nỗ lực sự lý thỏa đáng bắt đầu trên biển.
Chủ tịch chính nghiệp vương hộ ninh hẳng đề,
Trung Quốc coi Việt Nam là yêu tiên hàng đầu trong ngoài rao lắng viện,
đông chỉ nhất chỉ tăng cường kết nối chính lực,
sẵn sàng mở rộn nhục khẩu nông sản Việt Nam,
và quyền thích các gần nghiệp đầu tư và phía tế số hạn tân.
Hành nhà lãnh đạo thống nhất để mạnh hấp tác ít tế,
giáo rục đặc biệt là giáo lưu thi hiện trẻ.
Hãy bên cũng kăng kết uống hộ lẫn nhau tổ chức tốt các sự kiện đà phương,
trong tơm là năm 8h, hành hiệp Trung sọng hay sáo tại Trung Quốc
và năm 8h, hành hiệp Trung sọng hay bởi tải Việt Nam.
Nhằm hiện thử khoảm một tiêu phát triển và cộng đông chia sẻ thương lai coi nghĩa chính lực.